let's go to um we want to go next let's
go to uh
wait whoa we've got a lot oh how about
flippy from
indiana flippy from indiana you're on
the air
flippy from indiana please unmute you
are on the air my friend
and last opportunity for flippy from
indiana to unmute and talk to me
hi can you hear me yes i can hey david
it's me
um i just was wondering if you've ever
reconsidered making an only fans
sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making it only fans
uh you know
uh gardening season is over and it's
time for you to show us your zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks to be
perfectly frank flippy
that works too yeah uh no but i am on
cameo which i think is like the work
safe only fans right
well that works well thank you and by
the way where does the name
flippy come from oh just an alias online
oh does it have any meaning no does it
relate to like a
floppy disk for example remember those
five and a quarter inchers
oh it's supposed to be like flippy
floppy like a stupid way to call
flip-flops
oh i got it by the way are you cleaning
a violin in the background
i know it birds sorry oh it's a bird oh
okay um all right very good well listen
i
really i really appreciate the call
flippy
all right thank you have a good day all
right that is a perfect phone call so i
think we're gonna have to end on that
i do apologize i wasn't able to get to
every call
um but we got a wide variety from all
over the world
and we will certainly have to do
something with
uh with that call thanks everybody i
hope to get to more calls next time we
will take a quick break
and be right back after this